امنه وهذه الوحده قامت بوضع خريطه
مفصله يمكن اجلاء اجلاء مناطق محدده بدلا
من اجلاء المنطقه برمتها من سكانها وفي
الشريحه هنا ترون هذه الخريطه والتي تم
تقسيمها الى قطاعات وكذلك صوره توضح ذلك
باللغه العربيه حتى يفهمها المدنيون الجيش
ايضا قام بتنفيذ هدن مؤقته تمكن المدنيين
من الانتقال
والاجل ورغم رفض حماس لذلك وحتى هاجمت
قوات الجيش التي كانت تعمل على توفير
الحمايه للممرات الانسانيه
الامنه لدي لدي طلب من المترجمين بان يقوم
بالتبه في حديثك حتى يستطيع مواكبه حديثك
الترجمه
امس جنوب افريقيا ذكرت
بان الجيش كان ي اعطى مده لمده 24 ساعه
للمدنيين من اجل اخلاء المنطقه وفي حققه
الامر الجيش حث المدنيين على الاجلاء نحو
جنوب غزه لاكثر من ثلاث اسابيع قبل ان ب
بدايه عملياتها البريه في المنطقه ثلاثه
اسابيع وفرت
لحماس معرفه مسبقه بشان مكاني تنفيذ
العمليات من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي تلك
المهله للاخلاء المؤقت هي من باب
المعلومات العامه
وا
وتشويه حقيقه الامر هو ربما مرتبط بعدم
معرفتهم لتلك الحقائق ومحاول تشويه تلك
السرديه الجيش الاسرائيلي يطبق عدد طبق
عدد الم التدابير
الاضافيه من باب التحوط واتخاذ التدابير
تحوطيه بموجب قانون الانسان الدولي فعلى
سبيل
المثال وفرت تحذيرات مسبقه بشان هجمات حيث
تسمح ظروف
بذلك الى الان الجيش قام باسقاط ملايين
المنشورات والمناشير على المناطق التي
متوقع مهاجمتها تتضمن ارشادات وتوجيهات
باخلاء المناطق وكذلك ارسلت عدد لا حد له
من الرسائل عبر اذاعه وعبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تحذر المدنيين من الانفصال
من تطلب منهم الانفصال عن حماس وكذلك اجرت
مئات الالاف من الاتصالات الهاتفيه تحذر
المدنيين من
حجمت وهذا يتطلب الوقت والموارد والعمل
الاستخباري والجيش استثمر في كل تلك
الاجراءات من اجل انقاذ حياه المدنيين هنا
ترون ح الحباس حساب الجيش الاسرائيلي
باللغه العربيه يوجه المدنيين للاخلاء
واللجوء الى مناطق محدده بما في ذلك بعض
الملاجئ في المناطق المجاوره ولكن المدعيه
وبشكل مدهش تد دعي بان تلك الجهود بحد
ذاتها هي ذات طبيعه مرتبطه بالعباده
الجماعيه بمعنى اخر ان التدابير التي من
شانها الحد من الح وقوع اذن بالمدنيين
يتجاوزوا متطلبات القانون الانسان الدولي
وهذا دليل وفقا للجهه المدعيه اثبات على
نيه اسرائيل ارتكاب اعمالي اباده
جماعيه في حقيقه ان الامر هو نق ذلك
تماما النقطه الثالثه والتي تتعلق بالوضع
الانساني كثير من الاهتمام تم ايلاه من
قبل جنوب افريقيا لهذه النقطه رغم جهود
اسرائيل للحد من الضرر وذا ما من شك
بان الكثير من المدنيين في غزه عانوا جراء
هذه الحرب التي بداتها
حماس وفي الوقت الذي تسعى فيه اسرائيل
للحد من الاذى في صفوف المدنيين فان حماس
في المقابل تقوم بكل ما في وسعه من اجل
استخدام المواطنين المدنيين والبنى
التحتيه المدنيه من اجل حمايه نفسها
وتقوض الجهود الانسانيه التي تهدف الى
تخفيف معاناه والام الشعب
الفلسطيني
و تجدون مزيدا من الاثباتات والادله في
الجزء الجزء الرابع من المجلد الثاني
والان تحدث عن بعض الجهود الانسانيه التي
انخلط فيها اسرائيل والسيد سدف سيتوسع في
تلك
التفاصيل
اسرائيل كرست وحده عسكريه اسمها
جتات مهمتها التنسيق بشان عدد من الجوانب
الانسانيه
كوجات
التي
قامت بفتح معابر مثل معبر ايرس والذي كان
قبل السابع من اكتوبر اكثر من 20 الف
فلسطينيين كانوا يعبرون الى داخل اسرائيل
يوميا لعمل هناك جنوب افريقيا عرضت خريطه
تظهر معبر ايرس
مغلقا لكن ما فشلت في الاشاره اليه هو ان
المعبر تعرض للهجوم في السابع من اكتوبر
من قبل حماس ما اودى الى قتلي
واختطاف عناصر كوجات والحق دمارا وضررا
بالمعبر ولكن رغم ذلك كوجات او وحده كوجات
كانت تعمل على على مدار الساعه لقيام
بمهامها والموظفون
بادروا قاموا بتنفيذ عدد المبار الدرات
والتي ساذكر بعضا منها
ولها كوجات ادارت اليه
تتعلق بتحديد الاحتياجات في غزه وتقوم
بذلك بالتعاون مع الامم المتحده وغيرها من
المنظمات والاجهزه الاموميه والحكوميه
التي يجلس ممثلها في مكتب كوجات وتستخدم
هذه الاليه لمساعده الدول المانحه
والمنظمات الانسانيه تحديد اولوياتها فيما
يتعلق بالاحتياجات الانسانيه وذلك من اجل
تخفيف الوضع الانساني في على الارض
كوجات تسهل وتيسر دخول المساعدات
الانسانيه والاغاثه الى داخل غزه اسرائيل
وخلال تصريحاتها الرسميه قالت انه لا حدود
لكميات الطعام الغذاء والمياه
وال الخيام
والادويه ولزياده تلك الكميات قامت كوجات
بفتح معبر كرم ابو سالم كما اقر بذلك قرار
مجلس الامن
2702 رغم تعرضه للقصف من حماس اسرائيل
ايضا عرضت على زياده ساعات عم لذلك المعبر
اذا كان هنالك امكان لزياده عدد المساعدات
والشحنات الى داخل قطاع غزا ثالثا كوجات
عملت على تعزيز الخدمات
الصحيه وسهلت
ويسرت رغم صعوبات اللوجستيه قامت بانشاء
اربع مستشفيات ميدانيه ويجري العمل على
انشاء مزيد من المستشفيات وكذلك
مستشفيان عائم كذلك سهلت وصول سيارات
اسعاف وكذلك نسقت عمليات اسقاط جوي
لمساعده انسانيه من قبل من قبل الاردن
وقامت بالتنسيق مع الجيش الاردني
وال لكن هذا لا يعني انه ينبغي بدل قيام
بالمزيد ف صعوبات جمه موجوده وتتغير وفقا
لتغير
الظروف في هذه الحرب ولكن من الكافي القول
ان تهمه الاباده الجماعيه في ظل كل تلك
الجهود الحثيثه
والكثيفه لا يمكن
تصورها وهذه حقيقه ولكن من ابرز التحديات
هو ان
حماس تسيطر هي التي تقوم بالسيطره على تلك
الشحنات وتلك الكميات
وتشرف على توزيعها وهي تقوم بمصادره تلك
المساعدات على حساب مطن وهذه تغريده تشير
الى انه تم سرقه الوقود واجهزه الطبيه من
قبل عناصر حماس من احد المرافق التابعه
لمنظمه غوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
انرو
وهنا
نرى حماس تقوم بالسيطره على احدى شاحنات
المساعدات وهذا مثال اخر ولان حماس
ولسنوات طويله تستخدم الشحنات المساعدات
لتهريب تهريب الاسلحه فان التفتيش الامني
لكل الشاحنات والشحنات امر ضروري بموجب كل
القوانين الدوليه حماس مرارا وتكرارا قامت
ب نهب الوقود والذي استخدمته لاغراض
عسكريه وذلك من
اجل تشغيل اجهزه التهويه في شبكه الانفاق
التي تستخدم في شان هجمات ضد اسرائيل ولكن
رغم ذلك ومع التنسيق مع الامم المتحده
فيان اسرائيل مكنت من وصول ودخول الوقود
الى غزه وذلك من اجل خدمه المرافق
والمنشات الاساسيه مثل محطات الصرف الصحي
ومحطات تحليه المياه
وكذلك خدمات
الاتصالات اللاسلكيه وساعدت اسرائيل
المنظمات الدوليه والدول المشاركه في جهود
الاغاثه لتجاوز كل تلك العقبات وبشكل ثابت
زادت كميات المساعدات والخدمات المتوفره
للسكان وال في غزه وكما سيتم وصفه من قبل
السيد
سلندر هنا صوره ل اجهزه
الخداج وهنا صوره لقافله من السياره
الاسعاف التي
اشرفت كوجات على
تسييرها هذه ايضا صوره من الشاحنات وصوره
اخرى لعربات الاسعاف واخيرا مزيدا من
الشحنات والشاحنات التي تحمل المساعدات
المتوجهه الى غزه السيده الرئيسه اعضاء
المحكمه المقرون في الوقت الذي يتيح لي
وصفت نزرا من جهود اسرائيل للتخفيف
من الاذى الذي حاق بالمدنيين وتخفيف الوضع
الانساني ولكن هذا الجزء اليسير
كاف
ليثبت مدى انحياز عرض الجهه المدعيه اتجاه
تلك الوقائع والحقائق وكاف للاستنتاج الى
ان نيه ارتكاب
اعمال اعمال بات جمعيه باطله لا اساس لها
اذا كانت نيه اسرائيل هل كانت ستؤخر
العمليات البريه لاسابيع
وتحث المدنيين للجوء الى مناطق امنه
وتضحي بذلك في المزايا المتعلقه بتلك
الهجم بتلك العمليات
وتحدد اماكن يلجا اليها المدنيون
وكيف
ل الاجلاء
او هل كانت لتكرس وحده تضم خبراء تعمل على
تسهيل وتيسير دخول المساعدات الانسانيه
ومواصله قيامها بمهامها رغم قتل واختطاف
عناصر
منها عندما تسيطر منظمه ارهابيه على
المدنيين همها اباده جيرانها بدلا من
حمايه شعبها ومواطن
بالتاكيد سيكون هك تحديات وصعوبات جمه
تتعلق بحمايه المدنيين وهذه تفاقمت من
خلال الطبيعه المتغيره والديناميكيه
للعمليات العسكريه في المناطق المدنيه حيث
استخدم العدو المستشفيات والمدارس والبنى
التحتيه لصالحها هل كانت اسرائيل لتستمر
بالعمل مع المنظمات الانسانيه ودول
والتواصل معها بروح المبادره للبحث عن
حلول لتجاوز تلك العقبات والتحدي
هل هذه تنم عن نيتها لتدمير هذا
الشعب ما تقوم با اسرائيل هو على نقيض
وجود نيه
لتدميره النيه لارتكاب اباده
جماعيه ليس لا يمكن استنتاجها من تلك
العمليه بهذا اختم مراع شك جز لكم حسن